[Musique]
et
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire les adhérents du parti des
républicains ont choisi valérie pécresse
comme candidate à l'élection
présidentielle
elle va avoir fort à faire avec marine
le pen eric zemmour et emmanuel macron
qui espère bien continué d'assécher
l'électorat l air mais avec une gauche
en dessous de 30% des intentions de vote
la droite paraît sûr de l'emporter mais
quelle droite il y en a plusieurs
désormais d'autant plus puissantes
qu'elles semblent irréconciliables sur à
peu près tous les sujets pour débattre
nous avons invité chaque camp fini vous
êtes avocat c'avait été chroniqueur chez
laurent ruquier au point dans les
grandes gueules chez rmc là vous y êtes
encore chaque fois vous y incarnez la
droite mais la droite libérale et même
libertaire il y a deux semaines sur rmc
vous êtes élevé publiquement contre ce
que vous appelez la nouvelle doxa qui
veut qu'à droite désormais je vous cite
si vous ne vomit c'est pas votre haine
des étrangers des musulmans quatre fois
par semaine vous êtes un islamo
gauchiste est ce que pour vous je vais
poser la même question à mes trois
autres invités la france aujourd'hui
elle est majoritairement de droite pour
vous c'est un effet d'optique au fond
parce que les intentions de vote plus la
sur-représentation des des chroniqueurs
dit de droite dans les médias
aujourd'hui nous donnent au fond une
idée une illusion d'une france de droite
qui ne le serait pas oui je pencherais
plutôt pour la deuxième option je pense
qu'il ya en ce moment une mode
intellectuelle et médiatique très forte
mais qu'il ya des fondamentaux en france
en attachement l'égalité notamment qui
parfois verse dans l'égalitarisme qui
reste très fort et aussi un goût de la
fraternité qui reste fort et donc je
pense qu' elle n'est pas très
profondément et si profondément de
droite et j'observe d'ailleurs que les
candidats dits d'extrême droite eric
zemmour marine le pen on sur les
questions économiques et sociales en
réalité des programmes plutôt à gauche
ce qui me fait penser que la france
n'est peut-être pas c'est à droite que
ça françois bousquet vous êtes rédacteur
en chef de la revue éléments l'organe de
la nouvelle droite telle qu'elle avait
été théorisée par alain de benoist vous
êtes également le directeur de la noue
librairie la librairie de la nouvelle
droite vous êtes l'auteur de la droite
buissonnière c'était sur patrick buisson
puis son pardon que j'ai reçus dans
cette émission plus mais aussi de
courage manuel de guérilla culturel
votre dernier livre c'est biopolitique
du coronavirus télé travail famille
patrie j'aime beaucoup ce titre édité
par la nouvelle librairie même question
la france était le majoritaire mans de
droite si on s'en tient aux projections
des sondages oui de fait il ya un
alignement à droite du paysage politique
français vous rappelez il ya 30 % de
français qui seront prêtes à voter à
gauche donc on imagine que le restant à
voter à droite mais qui à droite en
effet la droite c'est un peu comme les
fromages y en a pour tous les goûts il
ya va de la droite au lait cru il ya des
boîtes authentique ya les droites qui ne
sont pas authentiques des droites
libérales et droite populiste de fait la
candidate du deuxième tour 2010 est
classé à l'extrême droite récuse l
totalement le clivage droite gauche donc
c'est le paradoxe les énormes comme
emmanuel macron d'ailleurs comme normal
qu'on sait et c'est en même temps et la
droite et la gauche tandis que marine le
pen passe par dessus des partis par
dessus des clivages horizontale droite à
la gauche pour s'appuie sur un clivage
verticale les élites et le peuple elle
c'est le peuple a donc ce clivage est en
a du plomb dans l aile me semble-t-il
aujourd'hui aurélie gros vous êtes
membre du parti des républicains que
vous avez quittez non vous l'avez été un
vous l'avez été vous l'avez quittée en
2019 après l'échec des européennes
vice-présidente de grand paris sud maire
de coudray montceaux j'avais créé un
mouvement de concertation citoyenne
baptisait la france vraiment qui
encourage les électeurs à peser dans le
débat politique pour vous justement
cette france est-elle de droite mais
écoutez facialement si on regarde les
chiffres effectivement je dirais comme
mes collègues autour du plateau si on
regarde les chiffres on al'impression
effectivement qu'il ya une tendance
plutôt à droite mais quelle droite c'est
bien le sujet du débat si on considère
que les populistes les démagos sont de
droite si on regarde emmanuel macron il
est quoi est-il réellement de gauche ou
de droite ou de droite et de gauche moi
je m'intéresse beaucoup plus à la
majorité silencieuse à tous
les électeurs qui vont pas forcément
voté ou ceux qui se trouvaient sur les
ronds points lors de la crise des gelées
jaune et qui ont des messages justement
sociétale économique sur l'emploi et ces
gens là ils demandent pas forcément un
programme de droite donc je pense pas
forcément que la france est à droite et
qu'aujourd'hui on puisse réellement
avoir ce constat là c'est un constat
facile qui est souvent servi par les
populistes william tell vous êtes
président du think tank indépendant
luminaires créé en 2018 pour travailler
à la ''refondation'' idéologique de la
droite avec une vision gaulliste
réformatrice attaché à la grandeur de la
france est guidé par l'intérêt national
pour un gaullisme du 21e siècle au fond
c'était le titre de votre rapport en
novembre 2020 la france s'est elle
majoritairement de droite pour vous il
ya une poussée des aspirations des
français de plus en plus à droite que
regardent les différentes enquêtes
d'opinion soient les différents sujets
comme sur les questions de sécurité sur
les questions migratoires sur les
questions économiques sur les questions
d grandeur de la france etc vous avez
une poussée de plus en plus des français
avoir des aspirations de droite et
malgré tout quand on prend le paysage
politique emmanuel macron un
positionnement qui est hybride à la fois
et de gauche et de droite et marine le
pen se réclament ni de gauche ni de
droite non quand on prend le champ
politique en termes d'intentions de vote
le paysage est beaucoup plus nuancée et
surtout pour rejoindre ce qu'a dit
charles consignés en fait si les
français sont majoritairement de plus en
plus à droite par contre les différents
systèmes de pouvoir que soit
l'administration publique le système
médiatique et la pensée ce qu'on appelle
la pensée dominante sont toujours sur
des ressorts majoritairement de gauche
fondé depuis la révolution française sur
la question de l'égalité et sur la
question d'égalité à une opposition que
les questions de la liberté qui est pas
l ordre qui est principalement de droite
donc du coup pour répondre à votre
question il est plutôt nuancé et si on
prend les différents panoramas en fait
chacun des candidats a des traits de la
droite emmanuel macron empreinte campera
typologie de rené rémond la droite
orléaniste plutôt libérale valérie
pécresse eric zemmour vont emprunter le
champ de la droite bonapartiste et
marine le pen va emprunter les champs et
les rhétorique de la droite légitimiste
et même quand on procède ce panorama là
les frontières sont beaucoup plus flou
dans la mesure où valérie pécresse
emprunte à un discours qui est plutôt
libérale qui marche sur les terres des
manuels macron eric zemmour emprunte un
terrain qui emprunte de droite
légitimiste donc sur les terrains
également de marine le pen donc le
paysage est très flou et pour
récapituler les français veulent une
inspiration de droite mais ils sont
opposés dans leur aspiration depuis
plusieurs années sur cette volonté de
droite depuis 1981 merci thierry des
reymond l'auteur dé droite en france il
y avait des constantes de droite si on
regarde aujourd'hui l'échiquier
politique alors à la fois avec les
contes quatre candidats presque déclaré
pour me emmanuel macron alors surpoids
et manuel macron qui est qualifié de
droite a même si lui dis moi je suis
voilà mais il est qualifié de droite
vous prenez valérie pécresse marine le
pen et eric zemmour mais si vous y
ajoutez tous ceux qui ont de la fluence
eric ciotti va avoir de l'influencé sur
la candidature de valérie pécresse
edouard philippe jean castex les
premiers ministres de débats gueule
macron gérald darmanin son ministre de
l'intérieur si vous ajoutez nicolas
dupont aignan nicolas sarkozy qui est
toujours là et qu'elle l'affluence ne
serait-ce qu il est sur les électeurs de
l'est républicain puisqu'il est le
dernier président des républicains avoir
été élu si vous prenez tout ce monde là
qu'est ce qu'ils ont en commun sur et
puis avec vous 4 d'ailleurs déçu qu est
ce qui est commun à tous ces gens sur la
typologie évoqué de rené rémond de fait
la seule droite authentique c'est la
droite légitimiste on va pas faire un
cours d'histoire des visées politiques
mais cette droite est morte aujourd'hui
éric zéni eric zemmour ni marine le pen
de s'en réclament je ne pense pas que
marine le pen sache se distingue au
classique dans les sciences politiques
il reste une droite orléaniste poste
orléaniste deux en fait
macro nien peut-être que pécresse en
tout cas quand elle crée son mouvement
libre pour s en réclame et qu'après il
ya une droite bonapartiste un
bonapartiste sous la forme que le
populisme a pu prendre et que zemmour
que zemmour incarne aujourd'hui où
marine le pen d'uranium chiraquie hier
où jacques chirac en campagne en
campagne c'est parce qu'il ya c'est
docteur jekyll et mister hyde il ya un
visage face caméra pendant pendant le
pendant la campagne où chirac était
était une bête de foire une bête de
scène exceptionnelle comme marine le pen
aujourd'hui puis après il ya l'exercice
du pouvoir et les oreilles de pouvoir y
les orléanistes par la droite de
gouvernement depuis depuis une éternité
j'allais dire qu'est ce qu'elles ont de
qu'est ce qu'elles ont de commun rien
rien rien comment rire les gens j'ai
réseau tela rien en tout cas entre cette
droite bonapartiste
c'est à dire aujourd'hui populiste rien
puisque sa droite bonapartiste ou
populistes recycle des thématiques que
la gauche a échoué à porter entre autres
la thématique égalitaire si on regarde
les secours du r'n duras nationale
aujourd'hui il s'adresse prioritairement
à la france dé gilet jaune des ronds
points au bout d'un à la france des
bottins au succès des bouddhas dont on
ne parlait pas jusqu'à hier à paris donc
c'est à cette france là qu'elle
s'adresse à l'est ni droite ni gauche de
fait dans les catégories populaires le
clivage droite gauche ne portent
retrouve très peu d'écho sinon
n'expliquerait pas le passage le
basculement de l'électorat communiste il
ya 30 ans vers vers le rn aujourd'hui si
si les ouvriers étaient où les employés
étaient autant attaché à ce clivage mais
ils sont restés fixés à à leur matrice
originelle amatrices jurassienne
socialiste que sais-je révolutionnaire
c'est pas le cas ils sont ailleurs donc
pour moi oui alors je veux pas
monopoliser la parole
rien de comparable 2 et on va y avoir
très rapidement je le pense à rien comme
les brosses et c'est peut-être là
la faute des partis politiques on voit
que les partis politiques se reforme au
moment des élections c'est le cas dé
l'air aujourd'hui on est vu ils sont
montés à 150 mille adhérents il ya eu
une campagne qu'est ce qui a en commun
entre eric ciotti et valérie pécresse
pour moi je vous dis clairement rien il
ya rien en commun donc c'est des
logiques de partis politiques qui à mon
sens d'ailleurs brouille
la vision que les français peuvent avoir
de la politique en général et dessert la
politique et des politiques je
m'explique c'est à dire que les français
aujourd'hui quand vous allez sur les
territoires et moi j'ai l'occasion d'y
aller puisque je parcours la frange et
des antennes départementales un peu
partout en france on mène des débats les
personnes qui sont autour de la table
sont issus de milieux différents ont des
dés à spirit et différentes viennent de
partis différents souvent d'ailleurs et
échanges sur des sujets de vie et quand
il voit le spectacle en général un à
droite ça peut se passer d'ailleurs à
gauche avec les verts et le parti
socialiste quand ils voient cette image
de fausses réconciliation et est d'aider
des termes par exemple quand eric ciotti
a dit si jamais eric zemmour emmanuel
macron je soutiendrai eric zemmour je
pense pas connaissant bien valérie
pécresse que valérie pécresse ferait le
même le même soir qu'eric ciotti il
entend bien d'ailleurs avoir de
l'affluence sur
quelques années bien que les partis
politiques aujourd'hui lors leurs
failles à mon sens c'est qu'il n'y a
plus d' écoute du citoyen les idées ne
sont plus demandées aux citoyens et puis
des citoyens qui portent des idées et
une conviction c'est le parti qui impose
on est un peu dans le dans le système du
fan club et dans ces élections et dansez
dansez congrès qui porte un candidat au
final il ya un côté fan club donc ses
réserves et oui je suis dur mais vous
comprenez que je fais plus partie de
partis politiques parce que justement le
côté fun club moi je préfère la réalité
la politique par la preuve donc je
préfère aller au contact des citoyens et
je trouve que le citoyen a des idées
aussi et l'intelligence citoyenne ça
existe et je pense que des partis
politiques devraient faire différemment
et revenir à cette base là william t je
pense je pense que les différences entre
les quatre sont sur joué par la
compétition électorale il ya plusieurs
points soit compétition électorale c'est
qu'en fait depuis la mi- depuis la
révolution de macron 2017 qui a
chamboulé le jeu politique la plupart
des décors différents candidats emmanuel
macron eric zemmour valérie pécresse et
marine le pen se bat pour ce qu'on
appelle l'électorat laisse orphelin de
françois fillon donc du coup ça conduit
à une convergence des positions sur ce
type d'électorat levé sur les
différentes questions de françois fillon
sur les questions de liberté économique
sur les questions sécuritaires
migratoire etc il ya une forme de
convergence même emmanuel macron a
accordé un entretien à valeurs actuelles
alors qu'ils menaient originalement de
la gauche et même marine le pen s'est
normalisée depuis plusieurs années sur
les questions de dettes réformes
économiques et c'est donc à une forme de
convergence qui lie à la petite à la
compétition électorale qui l électorat
stratégique de françois fillon mais
deuxième point c'est comme vous êtes
dans une compétition électorale chacune
des personnes ont tendance à sur jouer
les différences pour essayer de se
démarquer l'un par rapport à l'autre
quand on prend les discours d'intention
entre valérie pécresse et eric ciotti
les deux se réclamer de françois fillon
est en fait ils ont ils ont deux
différences une différence de degré
raison d'un différend stratégique palais
pécresse pense que son électorat plus
naturelle est à la fois chez emmanuel
macron et une partie d'eric zemmour
alors que eric ciotti veut farine
stratégique c'est nicolas sarkozy en
2007 c'est-à-dire braconné siphonner
l'électorat de droite et d'extrême
droite pour espérer se qualifier en vue
d'un second tour face à emmanuel macron
mais quand on revient à l'origine de la
droite que la droite est une origine qui
est récente en fait jusqu'à jusqu'aux
années gaulliste muscat valéry giscard
d'estaing ou même plus tard personne se
réclamer d'être de droite et la droite
gaulliste disait en gros il n'y a pas de
gauche n'est pas de droite qui ajuste
intérêts de la france et qu'en fait la
droite a comme ans a réussi à revenir
comme sur les années post jacques chirac
à partir de nicolas sarkozy en 2007 et
surtout par l'arrivée de jean-françois
copé à la tête du parti qui a théorisé
ce qu'on appelle la droite décomplexée
et la droite en fait par rapport à la
gauche comme la gauche à a dans
l'imaginaire collectif a entamé la
révolution française et est plutôt
auréolé de la victoire de 45 alors que
c'est plutôt le général qui avait
emporté du coup incarner le camp du bien
et la droite était une forme de contre
révolutionnaires ont les vieux qui est
mouvement poujadiste dans les années 50
60 et c'est donc la droite est en
opposition par rapport à la gauche et
comme la gauche a dominé le champ
politique et intellectuel depuis la
grande victoire en mai 68 clé s'est
concrétisé par victoire politique de
1981 qui ont abouti un certain déclin
économique et social un déclassement de
la france du coup la droite revient sur
le champ mais comme une sorte de
contre-révolution qu'incarner par deux
mouvements la manif pour tous dans les
années 2012 2013 dans un mouvement de
conservation par rapport au basculement
des loi taubira et deuxième point le
mouvement des gilet jaune c'est la
première fois depuis depuis une
vingtaine 30 aînés depuis les lois sur
la question de la place étaient les lois
mitterrand qui voulaient plus
supprimer l'enseignement privé sa
première contre un tel mouvement
d'ampleur qui s'est basé sur un
mouvement sur la question de la
fiscalité écologique donc sur un
mouvement profond de liberté en termes
d'origine et de de motivation des
personnels sont mobilisés charles
consigne non s'est elle est intéressant
de votre question qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce qu'ont en commun tous ces gens qui
sont décrits comme de droite ou qui se
réclament de la droite je pense que
peut-être que ce qu'ils ont en commun
c'est ce qu'ils ont de moins
intéressants et et moi je dirais
peut-être un peu de plus sombre puisque
en fait qu'est-ce qui fait se retrouver
macron darmanin zemmour pécresse ciotti
marine le pen
tous ces gens là
c'est des discours très martiaux sur la
sécurité des discours très hostile à
l'immigration
et dans l'ensemble des discours assez
négatif en fait sur le sur le présent et
sur l'avenir et ça je trouve que c'est
plutôt le mauvais côté de la droite à
mes yeux d'abord moi je suis avocat
pénaliste et donc je constate tous les
jours les ravages de cette idéologie
sécuritaire qui me paraît complètement
déconnecté de la réalité
c'est-à-dire que quand j'entends
certains responsables de droite dire que
la justice en france est laxiste je ne
peux que les invités à venir avec moi
dans un tribunal correctionnel pour voir
que c'est pas du tout le cas et que la
magistrature est très largement sensible
si non contaminée par les discours
sécuritaires il n'y a pas une feuille de
papier à cigarette entre la plupart des
juges correctionnels et eric ciotti sur
le plan de la volonté répressive je peux
vous le garantir
et sur l'immigration qu'il faille
contrôler l'immigration d'accord très
bien tout le monde peut
s'accorder sur le fait que dire cela
n'est pas tenir un propos d'extrême
droite mais je comprends pas pourquoi
tout le monde a fini par se mettre parmi
ceux qu'on a cité au diapason sur cette
idée que les migrations serait
nécessairement une catastrophe
n'apporterait rien de bon et de serait
l'une des causes sinon pour certains
comme eric zemmour la cause essentielle
de tous les problèmes de la france moi
je pense que c'est un raisonnement
d'abord qui est faux je suis convaincu
que la france a beaucoup d'autres
problèmes notamment le fait qu'elle ne
veut plus travailler et qu'elle est
complètement drogué à l'état providence
jusqu'à là jusqu'à la mollesse
généralisée
donc je pense qu'elle a d'autres
difficultés et je pense qu'il ya des
grands pays de droite si on devait
catalogué certains pays comme les
etats-unis qui se sont construits
magnifiquement grâce à l'immigration et
moi je suis de ceux qui luttent contre
aujourd'hui reconnaissez le qui vont
lutter avec trump qui luttent en effet
encore un peu avec buydens j'ai vu qu'il
allait reprendre certaines mesures de
trump évidemment qu'il faut pas ouvrir
tous les pays à tous les vents mais ces
discours très hostile à l'islam et à
l'immigration mais je pense que ce sont
des discours
électoraliste peut-être certains y
croient je suis convaincu que zemmour
est convaincu par ce qu'il dit je moins
sûr que marine le pen soit aussi
convaincu que ça parce qu'elle dit moins
sûr aussi pour pécresse et pour d'autres
participants qu'on a vu dans le débat de
l être je pense qu'il pourra y avoir
tout à fait un islam soluble dans la
république française qu'il ya la plupart
des musulmans sont intégrés à la société
française et donc voilà pour répondre à
votre question je trouve que le point
commun entre tous ces gens ça n'est pas
ce qu'il ait grandi mais tout ce que
vous voulez dire je me souviens qu'on le
disait beaucoup à droite alors sous
valéry giscard d'estaing c'était même la
majorité qui me disaient sous jacques
chirac
il y en avait encore bon nombre
sauf à des certains moments dans
certains meetings enfin il a encore bon
nom déjà souvent nicolas sarkozy y en
avait beaucoup moins et puis on a
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes
vous êtes un des derniers évitent plenel
vous
entendre un type de droite qui disait ça
ça lui semblait tenir aujourd'hui
c'était même au gouvernement salue
personne ne le dit
oui mais c'est ça que je trouve
catastrophique en réalité pas ce que ça
veut dire que les français ou qu'en tout
cas tous ces responsables politiques qui
vraisemblablement c'est vincent rolland
parmi eux que sera choisi le prochain
président sauf si mélenchon j'ai vu que
mélenchon était monté à 11% sba malin il
a fait 17
à 14 et mort est à 14 mais ensuite à
onze dont on sait jamais ce qui peut se
passer possession mais vraisemblablement
si le prochain président ou la prochaine
présidente est une personnalité de
droite ça voudra dire que cette personne
aura été élu sur une idée assez négative
de la france de ce qu'elle peut donner
de ce qu'elle peut devenir bien que ce
sera sur la sécurité et sur la liberté
qui est d'ailleurs revendiqué par la
droite que moi et si vous voulez à ce
que j'ai de droite en moi je pensais un
peu une idée de droite de penser ça hein
à ghlin quiétude qui m'habite c'est le
déclassement de la france le fait que la
france puisse de manière durable ou
définitive ne plus être une grande
puissance ça c'est quelque chose qui me
meut maquette me rend triste parce que
j'ai pas envie que la france devienne un
pays pauvre et je trouve qu elle le
devient de plus en plus parce que j'ai
pas envie qu'elle devienne un pays
secondaires et on voit bien sur la scène
internationale macron et peut-être pas
quand même le seul responsable mais il
obtient pas grand chose sur la scène
internationale on est plus écoutée on
voit bien que les américains nous
calcule pas pour parler un peu vite on
voit bien que les asiatiques pas pareil
et que ces gens là se parlent entre eux
et que nous au milieu on sert à rien
entre guilmette pour ça que je suis très
européen voire européiste puisque je
pense que c'est grâce à l'europe que la
france peut se faire entendre ça c'est
quelque chose qui m'inquiète mais je ne
pense pas qu'aujourd'hui dans l'état
actuel et j'espère que ça va se décanter
pendant la campagne et que ça va changer
pendant la campagne je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui dans les discours de toutes
ces personnes les clés et le message
porteur d'espoir est ce qu'ils vont
faire pour que la france reste et
redevienne une grande puissance écoutez
dans le monde pour l'instant j'entends
simplement des gens qui parlent à ce
qu'ils croient être les aspirations
d'une france qui se droitise ray c'est à
dire l'hydro parce qu'ils ont couru
après et zemmour pendant cette primaire
ils ont couru après et moore qui a mis
une identité comme seule marque de son
programme je suis au lait 1 ils ne
parlent que d'identité d'ailleurs pour
garder son clip de campagne il fait mais
moi personnellement moi il me fait une
fait peur son clip de campagne et
aujourd'hui quand on regarde
effectivement les candidats et leurs à
la primaire et si on prend l'exemple de
michel barnier qui était quand même on
peut dire européiste qui s'est mis à
critiquer l'europe parce qu'il était bon
ton de le faire voyez bien que les
français c'est pas c'est pas lisible
breux mais quand vous allez dans les
territoires que vous discutez avec les
français au quotidien quand vous êtes
sur le terrain en tant qu'élu je suis
dans mon mouvement je le suis j'essaye
en tout cas d'être au plus proche et
vous allez échanges et je vous assure
que les questions d'identité ne sont pas
les questions qui qui intéresse tout le
monde toute la journée il ya un mois par
exemple
l'égalité à la naissance et pète un
sujet qui qu'un des candidats à la
présidentielle pourrait porter plutôt
que de parler d'identité
la francophonie est peut-être un sujet
qui permettrait de parler d'identité de
façon positive or là on s'est mis et moi
je suis plutôt quelqu'un issu de la
droite donc plutôt de droite on s'est
mis à dans la stratégie du bouc
émissaire il faut trouver un bouc un
bouc émissaire à tous les maux des
français et il faut il faut éviter il
faut rentrer il se courent après les ans
les autres donc c'est relativement
insupportable moi je préfèrerais qu
effectivement on soit dans des dans des
projets pour les français et des projets
qui les touche pour toi sur la question
immigration sécurité de fait c'est la
seule chose qui distingue les l air de
macron
donc après tout le reste g économiques
convergent de la est-ce que c'est un
sentiment ce sentiment d'insécurité
c'est la thèse de plenel c'est la thèse
de la gauche c'est la tête c'est la
thèse de la sociologie institutionnels
et dominante qui est celle qui a
construit l'idée des paniques morales il
y aura une grande panique morale des
lieux blahnik identitaire est donc une
panique identitaire mais il ya une
panique de la panique aussi on n'en sort
pas c'est comme un complot du complot
c'est que vous avez une vision négative
de zemmour on ne sent pas de en disant
cela moi je n'ai pas été du tout est
terrorisée ou effrayés par pourquoi leur
âge et et j'adore les films de claude
sautet michel audiard par le clip de
campagne par l'équipe de campagne de
zemmour est-ce que c'est zemmour qui
donne le la oui et non c'est pas lui qui
donne le là c'est les sondages d'opinion
qui qui sondage après sondage dit que
deux tiers des français pensent qu'il ya
un problème de sécurité
non mais les médias chez les médias ça a
été dit tout à l'heure je veux dire il
ya rt il ya le phénomène bolloré qui a
changé la donne mais les médias
dominants ce que j'appelle les médias
centraux sont dominés par le gauchisme
culturel aujourd'hui je ne peux pas la
radio france je ne peux pas être invité
à france télévisions je serai jamais
invité mais pas en tant que mâle blanc
c'est pas parce que mes idées sont ce
qu'elles sont je ne serai pas invité
donc même le figaro je connais ses
rédactions la moitié des rédactions mais
peu importe est pas le sujet c'est pas
zemmour qui donne le la c'est l'opinion
bien sûr sur les sur les ronds-points
c'était la question du pouvoir d'achat
qui prédomine est
évidemment c'est évidemment une révolte
d'une protestation fiscal une
protestation
poujade east et dans la longue durée
toutes les protestations sont fiscales
étonnamment depuis cinq à six siècles
cet avis contre la guerre
particulièrement france contre la
gabelle l'intrusion de l'état de la peau
etc mais derrière derrière il ya près d
revendication de droits politiques et
les premières révoltes populaires et met
son centre l'info c'est quand même
fascinant de voir jusqu'au xxème siècle
les protestations contre l'impôt sur le
revenu mais le deuxième temps chez les
gilet jaune c'est la demande de
reconnaissance et la politique de
reconnaissance allemand je reviens au
bodacc que j'évoquais tout à l'heure les
bodins on n'en parle pas c'est l'angle
expliquer ce que sur les bonnes
audiences etc
c'est un tandem qui rencontre un succès
phénoménal faire aucun plateau il ne
faut jamais un seul plateau s'y montre
qu'air une fois par an et ils sont pas
programmées apparaît défait et feu jean
pierre pernaut le dessin en parler de
loin en loin mais de fait ils
remplissent les et nice toutes les
salles depuis 20 ans et viennent d'être
un film et ils viennent de faire un film
qui fn qui est d'une drôlerie mais
époustouflante qui est aussi grand que
les visiteurs un film populaire qui
renvoie une image positive pour le coup
une image positive de cette france
périphérique évidemment call un problème
d'identité elle n'existe pas dans les
représentations à l'université à la
télévision d'état
dans la grande presse ça n'existe que
dans les marges donc elle demande à
l'envoi est on est là on est là au bout
il n'y a pas que des minorités il voit
deux sociétés inclusives fonctionne à
l'exclusion de notes de nous donc
évidemment que ce thème et
si on pense que zemmour est la cause il
reste la conséquence on se trompe
complètement danalyse zemmour n'est que
la conséquence et ça ne s'expliquerait
pas le succès qu'ils rencontrent là
c'est quand même phénoménal
280000 bouquin vendu une vidéo en 24
heures et
construire une charte et les bolloré la
télé bolloré le fait de me
le phénomène nouveau j'en ai fini
aujourd'hui le phénomène nouveau il y en
a deux pour moi parce que macro et elle
en 2017 mélenchon ils étaient tous là
beaulieu rien n'était pas là et zemmour
n'étaient pas là c'est vraiment la
nouveauté et bolloré a cassé de fait le
monopole du gauchisme et culturel la
rente de monopole du gauchisme
culturelle sur l'institution médiatique
en tout cas dans les grands médias ça ça
va alerter sa perte et est atteint car à
part spoutnik est un cas à part tv
liberté est un cas à part mais dans les
grands médias centraux yapo jusqu'à
présent il y avait une parole ni tiens
je vous arrête on fait une pause et on
revient tout de suite après
[Musique]
la dette est elle la niche où les
nonistes de la croissance aujourd'hui on
continue à s'endetter et c'est même
devenu un modèle économique et ça depuis
une quinzaine d'années où vous avez le
la croissance qui n'est que la
croissance de la dette en fait est ce
que pour générer plus de profit plus de
richesse créée est ce que c'est bon
d'avoir injecté encore plus en fait
d'argent qui ne m'appartient pas falloir
du remboursement donner la réponse elle
est évidente pour tout ce qu'on a mis le
si peu de résultats mais c'est
pathétique là ils n'utilisent de la
dette pour manger tous les jours si vous
voulez pas pour investir et donc pour
payer les dépenses publiques de tous les
jours de fonctionnement et à partir de
ce moment là vous savez que vous n'allez
pas générer plus tard de l'argent avec
cette dette
[Musique]
la nouvelle calédonie foule ultime
référendum sur l'indépendance est
maintenue au 12 décembre quel poids
représente aujourd'hui à une moc ademe
les indépendantistes dans le paysage
politique en nouvelle calédonie qu il ya
une progression du oui le peuple
originel concernés par la dépendance il
l'indépendance il devance au camp
représente la france pour la société
calédonienne il n'y a pas eu de n 1
roger de la france et s'est alliée quand
même qu'ils passent à cet alien le
consumérisme d'assistanat ou ce que dit
j'ai un économisme une économie assistée
sous perfusion si on peut des
statistiques cruel pour trouver plus de
kanaks dans les prisons les hôpitaux
psychiatriques et marges des sociétés
que dans la réussite au niveau social
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat sur la droite
avec celle qu'on finit françois bousquet
aurélie gros et will i am tu es williams
puisque c'est à vous
pour partir de ce qui vient d'être dit
par françois bousquet il ya christophe
guilluy célèbre géographe très souvent
cité de préférence à droite d'ailleurs
qui a écrit dans le temps des gens
ordinaires son dernier livre qu'au fond
ce sont les gens ordinaires les classes
populaires la france périphérique pour
reprendre le titre de son aisselle
pucelle le plus fameux qui donnerait le
ton aujourd'hui eccoflow les débats qui
sont sur la place publique vienne n'ont
pas de des élus des dirigeants
politiques mais du peuple et de cette
partie du peuple qui a été la plus
invisible lisez donc quand on parle
d'identité quand on parle de pouvoir
d'achat quand on parle de sécurité c'est
ça remonte au fond de ces gens
ordinaires
qui d'après ce qu'il disait aurait
tendance à utiliser telle ou telle
politique au fond un peu comme une
marionnette à leur service les uns après
les autres reprendrait les thématiques
de ces gens ordinaires et onfray
d'esztergom campagne je suis pas je
m'inscris parfaitement dans cette
analyse il serait il sera assez fou de
croire que les politiques font une
politique de l'offre lorsqu'il présente
une offre électorale et fonds qui
répondent plutôt à une demande en fait
et eric zemmour je suis parfaitement
d'accord avec vous répond à une
conséquence de l'évolution de la société
ce qui s'est passé avec les catégories
intermédiaires et populaire que
christophe guilluy site c'est qu'en fait
ils ont repéré une conversion à partir
du à fin des années 90 début des années
2000 leur priorité était au départ les
questions économiques et sociales et
c'est pour ça qu'ils votaient
principalement à gauche pour rappel
françois mitterrand lorsqu'il est élu il
fait plus de 65 75 % parmi les ouvriers
et aujourd'hui le père this aussi se
représente que 3% des ouvriers donc il
s'est passé quelque chose parce que au
niveau de leur top priorité avant
c'était les questions économiques
sociales et maintenant ce sont passés
sur les questions régaliennes d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'à rapport terra nova en
2012 quelle majorité électorale pour
2012 préconisait pour la gauche de
gouvernement de passer d'une des
catégories dites populaires à des
électorats plutôt urbain métis et les
femmes etc c'est uniquement sur une
logique électorale parce que ses
électeurs intermediary populaire allait
opérer une conversion ce qu'elle a
appelé une conversion de conservatrice
est en fait la difficulté c'est que ces
personnes là n'était notamment marquée
par le discours de lionel jospin et
parle le tournant de la rigueur de
françois mitterrand en 1983 il pense
désormais qu'en fait les l'état ne peut
plus rien faire sur les questions
économiques parce qu'on d'une part nous
avons délégué une partie de notre
souveraineté à l'union européenne
notamment sur la question la politique
monétaire et que la question budgétaire
est désormais encadrée par les traités
tsg pacte de stabilité et c'est donc du
coup l'état sur les questions
économiques a beaucoup moins d'influx
ans donne un cadre mondialisée nos
protecteurs qu'auparavant et donc du
coup leur priorité puis désormais des
questions à un migratoire sécuritaire et
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont royan du coup
vers marine le pen eric zemmour sonore
volet de protection parce que s'ils
peuvent plus être protégée au niveau
économique il recherche une protection
au niveau de leur cadre de vie et donc
du coup la difficulté et vu que c'est
eux qui donnent le ton de la campagne
duc c'est l'électorat qui fait un
président ou qui défait un président
quand on dit qu emmanuel macron en effet
aucune voix auprès des catégories
intermédiaires et populaire ce n'est pas
vrai s'il est très élevé le différentiel
de voix entre son électorat csp +
électorat ce qu'on appelle csp - qui est
important il fallait il fait un nombre
de voix qui est beaucoup plus
conséquents notamment que françois
fillon en 2017 à partir du monde des
affaires c'est le steak toi qui avait
basculé et la difficulté c'est qu'en
fait les personnalités de droite
répondent à une politique de l'adq faut
une politique de la demande du coup ils
répondent à des aspirations électorale
mais ils ne font plus de politique de
l'heure c'est à dire qu'ils présentent
pas un programme créé sur mesure le
dernier à l'avoir fait il avait
rencontré un certain succès populaire
c'était françois fillon est le dernier
avant lui c'était plutôt le général de
gaulle en fait la droite d'alcool
nicolas sarkozy ni
tout à fait j'avais oublié sarkozy et la
difficulté c'est que la droite en fait
tu as loupé le premier tournant qui
étaient entamées au niveau anglo saxons
par margaret thatcher et ronald reagan
dans les années 80 à cause de jacques
chirac qui a refusé ce tournant qui
était en gros néolibérale pour emprunter
un tournant travail social qui était
caricatural
en 95 avec la question la fracture
sociale est en fait la droite empreinte
cette thèse là partir de nicolas sarkozy
en 2007 qui s'inscrit on appelle sarkozy
l'américain parce qu'ils empruntent les
thèses de george deubeuliou bouche et de
ronald reagan est désormais les à droite
française se convertit à cette terre là
sauf que la difficulté qu'ils ont
maintenant la droite française et c'est
pour ça que zemmour et marine le pen
monte autant c'est que depuis 2016 et
l'avènement du bric site de bord et
johnson et de donald trump la droite
mais au niveau au niveau occidentale a
évolué d'une nouvelle ère les patients
du norad qui est plutôt libéral sur le
plan intérieur mais très protectionniste
sur les questions extérieures c'est pour
ça que trump été
protecteur très très été marquée par
l'érection du mur la réindustralisation
et la question de l'intérêt national et
pour répondre à charles consigné sur la
question de la grandeur française en
fait il ya aucun politique arrive à
imaginer la grandeur française parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à imaginer ce que
serait le rayonnement français après le
tournant entamé par le général de gaulle
dans les années cinquante huit à 69 ce
que fait le général de gaulle c'est
qu'en fait ils participent il sait que
la france ne sera plus une grande
puissance du coup il entame il imite le
déclin français à travers la
construction européenne la construction
à 6 et le traité de l'élysée avec avec
l'allemagne est en gros se met sur une
politique indépendante entre la l'urss
et les etats-unis aujourd'hui nous
vivons un cadre qu'est ce qui est à peu
près similaire dire que l'union
européenne et la france ne sait pas qui
choisir entre devenir le vassal des
états unis ou sous traitants de la chine
et n'a pas de politique de grandeur et
de rayonnement sur ce plan là et sur la
question économique est en fête dont les
très dépendant de la politique
américaine notamment sur la politique
monétaire et sur la politique budgétaire
doit être comme on est comme on est
dépendant de différents contextes
internationaux que nous avons plus de
propre vision parce que l'europe est en
train de sortir de l'histoire il a été
marquée par la crise sanitaire c'est
pour ça que les politiques français
n'arrivent plus à gré devant durablement
en fait nos discours se rejoignent
à certains égards en tout cas sur ce que
marcel gauchet appelle le malheur
français tout à fait puisque charles
consignes hisser le sujet c'est sa
crainte ce qui est la nôtre sur ce
plateau dans une forme de déclassement
de rétrograde une femme de deux déclare
pardon
moi il me semble que le jeu non plus je
n'ai pas fais pas je vois pas à poser ma
question n'est pas là je regarde
simplement intrigué 7 ce démarrage
fulgurant et il me semble que sur les
thématiques gaullienne qui sont pas les
miennes qui sont les vôtres
au moins les miennes que les vôtres il
me semble qu'il apporte en tout cas il
ya une tentative un début de tentative
de réponse avec son reconquête avec un
discours assez volontariste je mette je
serai très juste un mot selon oui mais
il me semble que tous les partis ont
conscience de enfin tous les partis où
ils ont conscience de ce déclin de ce
déclassement donc notre programme pas
être fondamentalement positif puisque
sur tout le champ politique il ya quand
même la conscience d'un déclassement
puisque gauche qui appelle le malheur
français et se mêleront l'éprouvons les
prouve à travers les sondages assez
récent souvenez vous ayez une droite que
je trouve charles qu'on finit représente
encore aujourd'hui mais il est devenu
minoritaire la droite de répond par la
droite de chirac à l'époque une dame la
droite libérale qui était conquérante
qui disaient qu'ils pensaient qu'il y
avait une mondialisation heureuse mais
bien que le dit gerald istres était que
si la france acceptait de faire un
certain nombre de réformes libérales
mais elle s'en sortir est très bien mais
absolument et d'ailleurs il ya quelque
chose qui rejoint ce que ce que vous
dites et qui à mon avis différent si
c'est de droite c'est que zemmour ou
marine le pen extrême droite en général
n'incrimine jamais les français eux
mêmes c'est à dire et même dans ce que
vous dites sur les états unis etc on
n'est pas maître de ce qui se passe chez
nous parce qu'on est dépendant de la
politique monétaire américaine usta ça
veut dire que les français ne sont pour
rien dans ce qui leur arrive non mais
juste dit que j'étais c'était les
électeurs intermédiaire hip hop r penser
que en fait andré son virage ans se
disent que zemmour vous n'entendrez
jamais et d'ailleurs c'était justement
un chiraquien salat baroux l'ancien
secrétaire général de l'elysée qui
expliquait très bien dans le monde
pourquoi est ce que zemmour tentait de
réhabiliter pétain parce que c'est une
manière pour lui de dire que les
français ne sont jamais pour rien ne
songe et les spirou dans cette émission
j'ai fait ma photo yves le saux
oui mais c'était intéressant et il
disait aussi que ça ça permettait à
zemmour de justifier historiquement de
fonder historiquement une réunification
entre l'extrême droite et la droite
c'est à dire entre pétain et de gaulle
et maintenant extrêmement pas moi et ça
je pense que pourquoi est ce que je vaux
bien que zemmour sang partout m du
déclassement etc mais pour moi sont sa
rhétorique et son logiciel ne peuvent
pas enrayer ce déclassement puisque la
réponse qu'il y apporte c'est que la
faute de ce déclassement elle est sur
les immigrés et jamais il ne va dire aux
français vous avez une part de
ce discours la suite vous tenez il a été
tenu par ce qu'on a appelé les libéraux
au pouvoir depuis très très longtemps
mais paris les français ces noms tandis
que tous ceux qui voulaient réformer la
france qu'ils laisseront chirac
je ne rentre pas là dedans mais je veux
dire par là que vous avez perdu d'une
certaine manière cette bataille je suis
pas d'accord parce que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui la droite ne peut même plus
tenir ce jeune j'aime pas du tout
puisque quand vous écoutez pécresse elle
tient tout à fait ce discours quand il
parle des fonctionnaires en disant
qu'elle veut moins de fonctionnaires ça
veut bien dire qu'elle veut en fait les
faire travailler davantage
on sait que dans certains secteurs de la
fonction publique heureusement pas les
secteurs vitaux mais dans beaucoup de
secteurs il ya un problème de temps de
travail des fonctionnaires hidalgo en
est à essayer d'imaginer des arguties
juridiques pour permettre à ses
fonctionnaires de ne même pas faire
leurs 32 heures hebdomadaires donc on
est quand même à des niveaux de 2,2
délire in win oo donc je pense que il ya
là une vraie scission prévue le 3 ceux
qui pensent que les françaises sont pour
quelque chose dans leur déclin et
doivent se retrousser les manches et
ceux qui pensent que le déclin vient
d'ailleurs et que des français non car
ce soir en
réponse à ce produit s'est on est à la
croisée de deux révolte quand la révolte
des élites a théorisé par qui se fera
relâche que vous incarnez votre manière
c'est la faute des français vous êtes
dinsheim derma vous êtes aussi vous êtes
vous êtes des nazes vous mars et jeudi
nancy
des caricatures
à dessein je caricature à dessein pour
montrer le fossé qui en train de se
creuser le hiatus qui se creuse de plus
en plus sa très forte des élites est
évidente à c'est le coeur du sujet de
guy nuit c'est pas les élites mais
sont fatigués de voir et qui paye pour
cette année je suis pas tout je vous
rejoindrai électeurs de vos médias il ne
s'est pas des élites est sensible à la
question je pense que c'est un angle
mort des populistes de ne pas taper sur
les cas soc vivent au coeur de la france
périphérique le cas soc et le problème
du village c'est quoi le soc c'est le
site du champ
c'est le film les tuche voilà c'est si
vous représentez la france populaire
sous le prisme d'étudiants vous la
méprise et donc de narcissisme des
petites différences fait que dans cette
france périphérique dans cette france
pavillonnaire on regarde d'un oeil un
petit peu condescendant le gars qui
enquille toute la journée du ricard et
qui touchent le rsa il y en a un paquet
et moi je regrette que les populistes ne
s'adresse pas n'ont pas pas se marquera
la convoquer il avait sorti quoi comment
le cancer de l'assistanat mais c'est un
scandale et c'est nicolas sarkozy avec
travailler plus pour gagner plus ou
moins large mais aussi sur south et d'un
marché sarkozy il y avait le volet
social à côté du volet culturel il y
avait également l'identité nationale
mais il ya également ces skiffs moi me
frappe aujourd'hui dont on parle très
peu il ya une révolte on assiste de
nouveau à une révolte des masses
il en est à la croisée d'une révolte des
masses et d'une révolte des élites ce
que c'est ça vous le plus fascinant il
ya un terme que je chausse l'employé il
est il est incompréhensible pourtant il
au coeur de la théorie politique mais il
est dans la nature de la démocratie de
dégénérer en eau clos cratie look
l'ocrha si c'est le pouvoir de la foule
le pouvoir des foules le mot a disparu à
la fin 19ème siècle que la démocratie a
triomphé comme un triomphe elle voulait
pas qu'elle est trop nombreux porter qui
était le clos cratie et dans toute la
théorie politique de plus de 1500 ans
tous les grands penseurs depuis platon
on a théorisé cette hogra si cette
dégénérescence de la foule qui nous sera
sa manière trump 1 et peut-être demain
marine le pen et eric zemmour cercle ils
n'ont plus qu'une seule chose à faire
c'est à transgresser pour exister mais
dans une société dans une sphère
on ne se parle plus en un mot en un mot
quand même juste pour répondre à un truc
qui a été dit tout à l'heure
contrairement je pense que si le point
commun entre tous ceux qui ont gagné les
élections récemment que ce soit trump
aux états unis que ce soit en france
sarkozy
puis macron est un peu hollande entre
temps et un certain nombre d'autres
c'est qu'en fait il prend en moi je
pense qu'il gagne en réalité sur une
question économique c'est qu'ils
promettent aux gens un avis ils donnent
des raisons de les croire un avenir
meilleur pour leurs enfants sarkozy y
gagne sur une promesse pour le vide très
à l'américaine de france propriétaire de
travailler plus pour gagner plus de
l'effort le mérite récompense et macron
gagne en partie en partie parce qu'ils
les banquiers que du coup on lui fait
confiance on se dit il connaît
l'économie est d'ailleurs été ministre
de l'économie et il est jeune et il est
beau et laid marketing et du coup la
france sera moderne et donc elle sera
prospère trump y gagne parce que c'est
un grand patron et donc voulu c'est
parce qu ils agrègent jouer le rôle dans
l'église on allait mais parce qu'il a en
plus jouer le rôle du grand patron donc
on a bien compris que ça l'était et donc
c'est plusieurs banques l'amérique oui
mais c'est l'amérique du type justement
qui coule qui se refait qui osent et c
est tout ça ce sont à mon sens des
discours en réalité économique plus
économique qui laissait c'était faut des
qualités c'est de la corse et aurélie
d'abord dressé de la magique c'est
d'accord sur les français ne se parlent
plus sa chute tout à fait d'accord je
suis d'accord aujourd'hui il faudrait
redonner un peu plus de de parole aux
français est rentré vous savez je le dis
souvent mais mettre un peu plus de
démocratie participative au sein de la
démocratie représentative c'est ce
qu'avait promis emmanuel macron quand il
a été élu emmanuel macron a été élu sur
cette promesse là avec la grande marche
en faisant son programme auprès des
citoyens en expliquant que moi le jeune
beau blond je vais faire de la politique
autrement je vais casser un peu les
codes il ya plus de droite ya plus de
gauche donc il a essayé de parler
justement à cette france périphérique et
du dire voilà nous on va faire de la
politique différemment on va plus vous
casser les pieds avec des grands pontes
de la droite des grands pontes de la
gauche sauf qui s'est installée en
monarque républicain et saha s'est cassé
totalement la figure puisqu'il n'a pas
répondu à cette promesse et à cette
attente des français la figure pour
l'instant il est en tête dénoncent l
intrigue sûrs dans les zones non non
attendez je vais mesurer mes propos ça
s'est cassé la figure avec les jd genou
on a traversé quand même deux ans
d'enfer absolue où il n'a pas répondu
assez vite parce qu'il n'a pas voulu
d'ayew quelque part entre guillemets à
mon avis peur il a reculé we say die ça
va ça va s'éteindre comme ça s'est
allumé sauf qu effectivement on parlait
du pouvoir d'achat on parlait du
consentement à l'impôt et qu'au lieu de
donner des gages et de descendre dans
l'arène pour parler aux français de ce
consentement à l'impôt c'est important
c'est un des fondements de notre
république il en a pas parlé il a laissé
et la pauvreté il y avait la question
d'un choc ida fait oui il a fait un gros
chèque il avait d'agressions de la
fraternité aussi autour de tout ça la
france et j'ai jaune c'est la question
de la fraternité qui se retrouvent sur
les ronds-points je parle bien entendu
du début du mouvement et ensuite il
s'est rattrapé avec la gestion de la
crise il faut être clair puisque la
crise a été bien je suis bien gérée à
coups de chèques certes pas d'accord
non des sous cloche le gilet jaune le
maire a mis sous cloche les îles gilet
jaune on a payé pour sauver les
entreprises au maximum après noms seront
faits on s'est endettée ouais tout est
fait on s'est endettée parce que ça
laisse de screens et on n'a pas réglé le
problème de la santé de mepha ce qui
nous a sauvé à court terme est par
contre il a dégradé nos perspectives
économiques et de redressement pour
l'avenir de nos enfants pour une
centaine d'années quand on regarde la
gestion de la crise sanitaire par
emmanuel macron on voit par exemple sur
la crise de la dette qu'ovide il faudra
67 ans pour hambourg ça d'être commise
contre 7 ans pour les actifs à risque
l'action sera contenue par la part la
baisse psg sur emmanuel macron moi je
pense qu emmanuel macron ce que vous lui
reprocher d'être monarque républicain
moi je pense que c'est ce qui fait le
maintenir à 25% s'il était plus monarque
républicain il viendrait comme françois
hollande il serait complètement
démonétisé et la question essentielle
pour le pour le point l'avenir du pays
en fait c'est comment entamer la
question du redressement c'est pour ça
que moi je pense est est ce que je
voulais vous dire tout à l'heure sur
eric zemmour c'est qu'eric zemmour en
fait va servir d'aiguillon pour le débat
sur le débat parce qu'il permet à la
france et notamment i lévesque pour une
grande partie des français le fait de
renouer avec la grande histoire les
français veulent renouer avec l'époque
de clovis avec l'époque de saint louis
avec les peuples
la politique du général de gaulle la
difficulté qu'a
rx-7 cette intention de renouer avec la
grande histoire avec des intentions de
vote c'est parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
proposer un projet qui est concret en
terme de redressement national et
comment faire pour rendre sa grandeur à
la france pour reprendre les paroles de
donald trump en fait la difficulté c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur le
général de gaulle c'est que le général
de gaulle a très bien compris lorsqu'ils
des colonies lise la france notamment en
afrique c'est que la france ne peut plus
par ses seuls moyens ne peut plus
devenir une grande puissance et donc du
coup doit composer avec différents
ensembles et ce qu'il inscrit en termes
de trajectoire et ce qui est abandonné
jacques chirac et c'est peut-être le
dernier truc qui la regardaient en irak
mais ce qu'ils abandonnent les
présidents après jacques chirac c'est le
fait d'avoir une position intermédiaire
au conseil de sécurité entre les deux
blocs chine russie d'un côté et royaume
uni etats unis de l'autre et la france
de jouer un rôle d'intermédiaire
le porte parole des petits pays face aux
deux grands blocs très c'est le premier
point sur les scènes sur la scène
internationale au niveau européen la
france devait jouer une sorte de
contrebalancer avec les pays du nord
pour respirer une politique de grandeur
faire une europe politique par rapport
une europe économique et la france n'est
plus de voix au chapitre parce que la
france n'est pas assez forte notamment
pour dialoguer vis-à-vis de l'allemagne
c'est pour ça que françois fillon avait
proposé un projet permettra la france
dès la première puissance économique et
sociale en europe et pour contester les
amants c'est pour ça que je pense que
macro et néfaste parce que du coup même
si on prenait programme de françois
fillon aujourd'hui on attraperait pas
l'allemagne dans cinq à dix ans c'est le
deuxième point et puis après le
troisième point c'est une affaire de
rayonnement la france a toujours brillé
par ses grandes réalisations et par ces
grands esprits le plus grand moment de
l'histoire de france
le siècle de louis xiv qui a conduit au
siècle des lumières et aujourd'hui nous
avons plus d'atouts parce que notre
peuple est en déclin on le voit sur les
questions de l'éducation on est remplacé
par les pays est asiatique au niveau des
innovations en fait on se fait piquer
nos meilleurs talents par les américains
et donc du coup et en termes de
rayonnement que soient culturelles au
niveau de notre langue nous sommes en
déclin à tous les indicateurs et c'est
pour ça que les français de le renouer
non pas avec la grande puissance
diplomatique et militaire mais renouer
avec la question d'influencés je pense
qu'ils veulent renouer avec le siècle
des lumières pour rayonner dans le monde
entier inspiré le monde s'en fout
il nous reste six minutes donc je vais
vous redonner la parole à chacun et
histoire de conclure très provisoirement
bien entendu puisque cette affaire ne
fait que commencer on va voir
charles consigny
peux vous dire je pense que la campagne
va être intéressante je pense qu'il ya
quand même ce qui m'a ce qui me frappe
c'est que les français n'ont pas renoncé
en fait le fait qu'ils soient sensibles
aussi bien aux discours de zemmour qui
pour moi avant une grandeur d'opérette
en surtout si son projet consiste à soi
disant de vous faire retrouver la
grandeur tout en sortant plus ou moins
de l'union européenne en tout cas en
nous appuyant pas sur le l'europe pour
être grand et en
prétendant soigner la france en s'en
prenant à ces personnes d'origine
étrangère ou étrangers c'est une
grandeur de perdre mais j'observe que
beaucoup de gens adhèrent à ce discours
j'observe que les débats qui était assez
ennuyeux les débats de la droite les
dédouane les débats de l air était quand
même très technique et très
professionnelle en fait dont il y avait
une espèce d'exigence il se dit se tirer
dans les pattes sur les sur la mise en
place technique de leurs mesures
attention si tu fais ça ce serait
inconstitutionnelle ça coûtera 40
milliards d'euros mais non je t'assure
j'ai vu avec pour montrer que certaines
gouvernements ou chez des professionnels
mais mais mais c'était tout à leur
honneur si vous voulez d'une certaine
manière et puis désigne cette valérie
pécresse je veux bien qu en france on
est second ridicule des diplômés qui a
quand même fait sciences po hec l'ena je
crois ou deux peut-être normal sup dans
l'eau qui donnera le nom en tout cas
sciences po hec l'ena qui parle japonais
qu'il parle russe en faisant une place
de tête comme ça le meilleur élève un
peu
ça montre que et donc elle suscite un
certain intérêt bon tout ça me fait dire
que les les français n'ont pas renoncé à
être un grand peuple un grand pays je
pense moi aussi que macro est quelqu'un
d'assez néfastes j'ai détesté
personnellement sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire la manière qu'il a de prendre
les gens pour des pour un troupeau je
sais bien que de gaulle que vous avez
cités plusieurs fois disait que les
français sont des veaux mais je pense
que macro l'huile en est très convaincu
et il nous a fait rentrer dans l'enclos
sortir de l'enclos rentrer dans l'enclos
moi j'ai trouvé ça horrible et jeu et je
trouve son côté complètement lévitation
et c'est horrible je trouve qu'il est
trop du côté du cac 40 et que ça peut
rien donner mais voilà ils ont pas
renoncé donc je pense que la
présidentielle de 2022 va être
probablement un moment vraiment
intéressant françois bousquet plus court
plus court oui ça va être amusant
peut-être même sanglant donc ça va nous
changer c'était un puissant
barbituriques la primaire dlr je crains
que pour valérie pécresse se soit
toujours aussi soporifiques mais je l
risque d'être elle risque d'être hors
jeu si si zemmour et marine le pen ne se
neutralisent pas zemmour est un petit
peu le trublion qui surgit un peu comme
mr smith au sénat je trouve même s'il
n'a pas le physique de james stewart
loin de là mais il vient semer une
pagaille phénoménal donc il redistribuer
les cartes et valérie pécresse c'est bon
pour le camp et moore marine le pen
c'est mauvais pour le corps macro et
donne ans et je vois pas trop ce que je
ne vois pas trop ce qu'elle peut faire
puisque elle a dit tout et son contraire
c'est allé très vite il y avait une
partie des as l'air qu'ils allaient
voter bacrot mais je crois moi je crois
que ce sera même pas là le troisième au
bout la troisième femme jeu je craque
pour elle et pour les as l'air qui soit
en jeu ils sont deux tiers macro et un
tiers à thiers fillon donc ils n'ont pas
leur place dans le champ politique mais
grâce à zemmour donc merci merci à eric
on va on va enfin s'amuser puisque on
s'ennuyait depuis cinq ans et tous les
cinq ans et ce sera mon dernier mot il
ya cette grande messe traditionnelle qui
élections présidentielles qui relève de
la pensée magique parce que des cons
quand on dépose son bulletin ça dure
qu'une fraction de seconde bien sûr mais
quand on dépose son bulletin jacques
chirac dans l'urne 1 on s'imagine par
une opération du saint-esprit qui va
faire le programme pour lequel je dépose
mon bulletin donc il ya un acte ii il ya
une croyance auto-réalisatrice dans le
vote qui fait que c'est un acte
d'espérance donc c'est un moment très
important tous les cinq ans il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui ce moment en plus ce
serait trop sanglant donc pour nous qui
aimons les clash des punchline en tout
cas pour moi
et les envolées lyriques je vais être
servi je me réjouis
encore des cours impératif en france et
d'ailleurs heureusement et c'est bien
moi ce que je propose c'est que en
contrepartie il y ait un peu plus
d'écouté des citoyens et un peu plus
d'intelligence citoyenne qu'ils soient
remis au goût du jour et j'espère que
grâce à ces méthodes est assez bonne
volonté qui sont qui se mobilisent et
qui ont envie de parler de politique
autrement qu'à travers les sujets
d'immigration et de prénom et de place
de la femme dans la société j'espère que
les français seraient intéresserons aux
votes et iront voter parce qu'on a vu
quand même une chute vertigineuse du
nombre d'électeurs dans les yeux et
c'est ça qui est un danger pour notre
démocratie donc quoique on vote
aujourd'hui il faut quand même les
invités essentiellement à se déplacer
aux urnes c'est important william t moi
je pense que les français voient
l'élection présidentielle comme une
élection importante parce qu'ils sentent
qu avec la crise sanitaire nous sommes
dans une position de déclin et qu'on ne
pourrait jamais se relever donc par
conséquent ils veulent renouer avec la
grande histoire ils ont compris qu'en
2017 ils n'ont pas élu le nouveau
président du si le président du nouveau
siècle mais plutôt le président de la
fin du siècle qu'elle a entamé la fin du
déclin entamé par françois mitterrand la
difficulté c'est qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé
alors qui est toujours un grand sauveur
par siècle on a eu richelieu louis xiv
napoléon bonaparte le général de gaulle
ils n'ont pas l'impression jolie de
trouver un sauveur et c'est pour ça que
nous avons d une fragmentation de
l'électorat parce qu'il ya pas un
sauveur qui peut se qualifier montré la
voie alors je pense au moins que si nous
n'avons pas de sauveur au moins les
débats et l'orientation du débat
permettront à la france au prochain
président à la prochain président
d'entamer le bon cap dans la mesure où
on reprend la ligne idéologique de
françois fillon qui permet de rendre
l'âme et la fournissent le gros des
clubbers moi je pense que ça nous fait
avec françois fillon s'est fait peur
parce que françois fillon en fait nous
répondent à plusieurs vidéos c'est qu'il
a compris qu'en fait la france et
l'histoire français se battait sur de
grands idéaux la question de la grandeur
et la question d'être universelle c'est
que la france n'ait grande que parce
qu'elle est un phare dans le monde
que je rêve dresser que c'est un autre
clivage à mon avis pour moi la politique
n'est pas un jeu et donc l'idée qu'on va
s'amuser qu'il va y avoir du sang et
cetera je pense est une idée qui est en
vogue chez les mots etc mais le stade
qui fait qu'ils vont pas gagner et fait
pour ça
ça reste un glas droite républicaine de
l'extrême droite c'est qu'il y en a une
qui jouent et l'autre qui quand même
trouve que c'est ce que dit christian
salmon qui très très à gauche très
mediapart mais qui a un cerveau qui s'en
sert bien tiens la bande et de bouquins
c'est l'ère du clash vers lui l'a
dénoncé terre du clash mais il est
normal qu'ils aient du clash puisque je
leur dis moi ma parole n'a pas droit de
cité dans les médias sans trop donc je
ne peux y rentrer que par effraction je
ne peux y rentrer que par la punchline
et la punchline condamne évidemment à
l'échec ce qui est malheureux c'est rien
que dans cette campagne électorale parce
que vont parler du système de santé dont
je reviens dessus et sur la gestion de
globice on écoute enfin les collectifs
citoyens comme collectif pour la santé
en danger qui compte 220 mille personnes
et personnel soignant et aujourd'hui je
pense que ça c'est des débats de fond
puisque l'immigration et ces gens là
c'est déjà dépassé de droite mal merci
tous les quatre pour ce débat merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]
oui